(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the question
how did we survive
before cell phones?
- Or mobile phones.
- Or smart phones.
Mobile phones.
- Or, no, that's all I can think of.
- I think that's what we call phones.
- Yeah this is a little something
that we're gonna try today,
a little something different
where we're actually going to,
we're calling this a
nostalgia, a nostalgia tour.
How do you say that word?
- Nostalgia.
- You don't say nostalgia.
- Nostalgia, no.
- Yeah 'cause it's like
when you get nauseous
thinking about things from
the past, you get nostalgious.
(chuckles)
- I didn't know that I felt
that sometimes, but I do,
I mean we may feel that over
the course of reminiscing
over our relationship with
phones before cell phones.
- That's an interesting
term, relationships.
- Because I just might
feel sick to my stomach
that this is how we used to live
or that I wish I still lived that way.
I haven't quite figured that
out but what I do know is,
frequently on Ear Biscuits,
we'll reminisce about things
so I just thought let's
reminisce within this category
of what phones used to be like.
- Right and so we've
thought of some things like,
remember when--
- Well don't say 'em yet.
- I'm not, I'm gonna make blanks.
I'm just making blanks.
- 'Cause I have my list,
you have your list.
- Remember when
blankety-blank-blank
blanka-blank-blank phones?
So that's how it's gonna
be and then it'll be like,
remember when
blankety-blank-blank blank phones.
- Right.
- But before we reminisce, let's
talk about the present-day.
I mean let's talk about the
reality of being tethered.
- Yeah I mean--
- Ironically,
you're tethered wirelessly,
wirelessly tethered.
Think about that, put that on a t-shirt.
I'm tethered to a wireless phone.
- That's not really a sellable
t-shirt I don't think.
Yeah last night Christy
and I went out on a date
and we're driving to
the restaurant, I mean,
when we're at the table having a date,
we're not that couple
who's just on our phones
and not talking to each other.
But there are some times
when something will come up
in conversation and the phone
will become a third party
to our date, like a third
wheel where it's like,
oh there's unlimited
information on this thing.
But--
- The challenge is
if you have to go to
the phone in the midst
of a conversation which happens often
and there are legitimate reasons to defer
to the internet in the
midst of a conversation,
often during an argument to get to a fact.
Argue with my wife all
the time about facts.
(chuckles) No I don't, you know,
just any time you need
to reference something.
The temptation once you have
access to all the information
in the world, you get your
information and you're like,
well what's on Twitter?
Did somebody like my photo?
- We were driving.
- Can't do that.
- We were driving and we were
already having a serious,
not a, we weren't having an argument.
- Just a serious--
- We were having like a--
- Discussion.
- Let's share things that are
in our hearts and minds with each other.
Let's get into that mode even
before we're at the restaurant.
- Did it happen naturally
or did you prompt it
like a youth pastor?
- I'd like to share something
from my heart and mind.
- Or was it just natural?
- It was just natural--
- Good.
- Our relationship is
as vibrant as ever and
that's not facetious
even though it sounded that way.
(Rhett chuckles)
Yeah we were just talking.
- You were just talking
like two normal people on a date.
- And I look over and she's on her phone.
- Oh--
- Unlike me,
she can do more than one thing at once.
So I do respect that.
- She's also, she's not driving so.
- And she's not driving.
I was driving and talking,
that's two things.
- Well you don't do that well.
- I was kind of making
an introspective point
and I thought it was a
very great opportunity
for connection and she was listening
but when I looked over there
and she was on her phone,
I was like, do you have to
be on your phone right now,
I'm kinda trying to make
a point about something.
This feels important to
me and she's like well--
- Look at this dog hug this cat.
- No, she was actually
talking to the babysitter,
coordinating the time that
we would come back home
so it was a legitimate
exercise but I was like,
'cause she was like, she has to leave
and now I know when we're getting back
and I have to tell her and
she needs to know right now.
So I was barking up the wrong
tree but I did feel like,
you know, before the cell phone,
you would coordinate all that,
you'd have to go through all
these great lengths to do it
but you weren't constantly
in conversation.
- Well and once you were
gone, you were gone.
You were gone.
- Yeah.
Unless it was an emergency.
Even if it was.
- What'd you do?
Tell people what
restaurant you're going to.
I guess some parents did.
We were never parents without cell phones,
so we don't know what it
was like to be a parent.
First of all, I don't remember my parents
having a date night.
That's like a modern invention. (chuckles)
But would they have told a babysitter,
they probably said, this
is what we're going to do
and this is when we're going to be back.
But they didn't say--
- I'm paying you to be
completely in charge.
- Yeah, right, handle everything.
- I'm not paying you to then text me
with every little thing.
- Sidebar.
I mean, your daughter is 15 years old.
- Yeah.
- Why doesn't she just do the babysitting?
She doesn't wanna take care of the kids?
- Well that's a good question.
That just doesn't work a lot of times.
I'll just put it that way.
- 'Cause I'm thinking about
instituting my date night
and just not having any childcare.
- Oh, we do that.
The kids are old enough
to take care of themselves
or Lily and Lincoln to
help watch over Lando,
but none of them can drive
and there's like logistics
that are happening like they
had to go to different places
and stuff like that.
- Right.
- So we have--
- Sometimes you gotta
cover it with an adult.
- We have an ongoing arrangement
so then she helps out
with things like date night too
but it's a much larger scope than that.
But I look over at Christy,
I'm like okay, okay,
I'm not gonna jump down
your throat about this.
But then I swear when I
looked over there again,
she was on Instagram.
I think so.
- Oh my wife is constantly on.
Well what my wife found
this year was Twitter
and that is just, I mean,
she's a Twitter hawk, man.
- But when there's, and
it's not like when we have
a spare moment, you just
find yourself reaching
for your phone and (mimics whip lashing)
pulling that thing out.
I mean it's almost a mindless
reflex to pull that thing out.
- Oh yeah.
In fact--
- Beyond it.
- I saw somebody tweet the other day,
do you remember what it
was like to just poop?
- Yeah without being on your phone.
- You know, what was it like to just poop?
Now I've made repeated pledges to myself
to not surf while pooping.
But I just can't stick to it, man.
- Have you tried putting,
have you tried pudding?
Have you tried putting--
- Pudding.
It goes right through ya.
- (chuckles) Have you tried putting a book
on the back of the toilet?
And then you're tempted to read it.
Have you tried that?
- Yeah well I used to read books.
- But I mean now that...
- I used to read books on
the toilet, let me clarify.
- Have you tried pulling the phone,
putting the phone away
and pulling out a book?
- Not since the phone was a thing.
I've taken a book to the crapper.
- Yeah but then you're on it too long.
Like the phone is the perfect thing,
you just get a little taste of--
- You shouldn't do any of that though
because sometimes you get
into an Instagram hole--
- And you're sitting there.
- Next thing you know,
you got hemorrhoids.
You just can't do that, man.
You shouldn't even take it in there.
It shouldn't work, it should
be like those grocery stores
that have some kind of
scrambler on the phones.
I'm just convinced.
What's happening in grocery stores?
There's a scrambler on the phones.
- They put one in the DMV, I
can pretty much believe that.
- I'm pulling up recipes because I'm
at the freakin' grocery
store and I got no service,
I got like one X.
What's happening there?
- I don't think they
have any reason to block
like cell signal in there.
I think it's the exposed
steel of the ceiling.
- You think it's being
blocked by just the structure.
- But that wouldn't make sense.
- Well how come you get
cell phone signals while
in buildings and offices--
- All types of structure.
- Like on the first floor
of a large office building,
your cell phone works.
Why doesn't it work in a grocery store?
- Must be the groceries.
- And just the grocery--
- I think it's the food.
- You think food is absorbing
the cell signals?
Yeah, maybe chips 'cause
there's a lot of chips.
The chips aisle has
gotten nothing but chips.
- Have you correlated the signal
to going in certain aisles?
- I've definitely never
gotten it in the chips aisle.
- Hmm, I don't know.
I can pull out my phone
right now and Google it
but I'm not going to.
- I think we should just put
our phones in a bag of
chips and see if it works.
- I mean this podcast is an exercise in...
I was gonna say stamina
but restraint is the word
I'm looking for.
Sometimes it's an exercise in stamina.
- Stamina.
- (chuckles) I think some
listeners are nodding their head
right now like yeah, I can
barely get through this.
But, restraint, because we're
not going to our phones,
we're just having a
conversation for like an hour
with each other, every week.
Boy that's healthy.
- I put my phone
on airplane mode when I
do this or airport mode
as you would say.
- Yeah I do.
- When I'm doing a podcast.
That's what I do.
Well let's reminisce.
- Yeah 'cause I've got a list
of things just not, it's
not in direct contrast
to the mobile phones,
it's things that are like,
until I started thinking about it,
things I just almost forgot existed.
Like the way my life and
the world used to operate
was so different.
- Yes and you'll find out
all about that in a second, but first,
we wanna let you know where
you can get this snazzy hoodie
that Link is wearing.
- Look at that.
- Which sometimes,
for some reason I call hoodies beanies.
They got a weird thing
in my brain that wants me
to call a hoodie beanies.
- Never been a beanie.
- Yeah 'cause I love beanies so much.
- There's nothing like
just wearing a shirt
and then realizing I could cover my head
with part of this shirt.
- And this hoodie has the
latest in hoodie technology.
It's called the drawstring.
Look at that.
It's a string that goes through the hood.
It can be tied, it can be left hanging.
It can hang at different lengths,
at which point it will
distress some people
depending on their
personality and disposition.
- Now my son told me that if
you tie your hoodies strings,
that means you're in a relationship.
- Psh.
- And if you don't--
- There's always something.
- It means that you're not.
You're single, you're dangling, but then,
or you're tied up.
- Well okay, you know what--
- It makes sense.
- You know what else
they're doing, at least--
- Dangling or tied up.
- They're doing it in North
Carolina because I learned this
from my nephews.
If you're in a relationship,
you wear the girl's scrunchie
as a wristband.
- Is that right?
- You were a wristband.
And apparently it's color coded.
Like a certain color is,
but definitely, the scrunchie on,
she gives you the scrunchie
it's like exclusive.
- Ooh, I've been scrunchied.
All right, go to Mythical.store and get--
- Scrunchies.
Hey we need to start selling scrunchies.
Eh, that's what the youth are into.
- Always looking for something--
- Relationship scrunchies.
Okay, did you say the website?
Mythical.store.
- Mythical.store I said.
So we got our lists here.
Let's see, I mean I've got
mine in no particular order.
You wanna go first, I don't know.
Hit me with one.
Let's reminisce.
- I'm gonna start with payphones.
- Oh payphones.
- Remember payphones?
- Not even phones at home.
- The phones you had to pay for.
- I'm gonna grab my dog.
- Yeah she's usually so
docile and just likes to sit
in your lap but she seems
concerned about something.
- She was afraid to come up here.
- She's intimidated by the
new innovation in hoodies.
Let me just give you a couple facts.
Well you know what, let's
just see how bad you are
with the numbers 'cause
that's always entertaining.
How many--
♪ I'm at a payphone ♪
- In 1999--
- How did that song even work?
- In 1999, how many payphones were there
in the United States of America?
- Well there's 50 states.
I would say there's probably...
In what year?
- 1999.
- Oh, 99.
- 20 years ago.
- Yeah but cell phones existed then.
- Cell phones were not in
wide use at that point.
- A quarter of a, half a
million payphones in operation,
or in existence?
- Not a distinction, just in operation.
- Well hold on, a lot--
- We're not talking about
like apocalyptic ones and next
to the salt and sea or something.
I'm rounding up.
- Quarter of a million.
- Two million.
- Two million?
- Two million in 1999.
And then how many in March of 2018?
- Well they're all still there.
They're just not working.
- How many are in service?
Many of them are not in service anymore
but how many of them are in service in--
- 50,000.
- Oh, yeah not bad.
100,000.
So there's 100,000 payphones.
Now this is super interesting.
A fifth of them are in
the state of New York.
A fifth of all payphones that are active
are in the state of New York, and--
- I wonder why.
- They, now,
doesn't it seem like it
would be something logical
if I told you like, there's
100,000 payphones left
and I got this all from a
CNN money article by the way.
I'm not just making this up.
If I told you there's only
100,000 payphones left
in the United States and they're all owned
by one billionaire or
all owned by one company,
that seems like, yeah,
there's one person who got
into this old technology.
- Yeah.
- No.
Those 100,000 payphones are controlled
by 1100 independent providers.
That was fascinating to me.
- I mean when is the last
time you used a payphone
and I don't even remember
really using payphones much
like back in the day.
- Well I'm about to blow your mind
because it's still a business,
at least in 2015 it was.
I don't know how many were in operation,
not many more than there are now.
In 2015, those payphones
in operations generated
$286 million in revenue.
- You talking coinage
going into the machines?
- Well I guess possibly maybe
collect calls would also
go into that number.
- Okay.
- I guess, I'm assuming
'cause it's the same provider.
- Wow.
- This is just fascinating me.
So they're very useful still
in certain situations like
when you're out of range, like apparently,
the payphones in Yosemite
Valley are very, very,
there's a guy who owns those.
- Ah.
- And he makes a bunch
of money off those.
- That makes sense.
- Because--
- There's no service.
- Cell phones don't work
in these national parks.
Also disasters like when
phones are, the cell networks
are overwhelmed or if
there's like a disaster
and they're completely capacitated,
payphones are very useful.
So you would think that,
okay, we've kind reached
some sort of stasis, 100,000 payphones,
probably what we need
in case of emergency,
but there's a weird
law that the FCC passed
that I didn't really read enough about it
to know exactly what was going
on but it essentially has
to do with the auditing that is required
and apparently the
auditing that is required
for these payphones by the
companies who are servicing them
costs more than they're
generating and so now,
it's becoming an unsustainable business
and payphones are going out of business.
Not the business to get
into unless they're able
to talk to FCC at least
as of March of last year
out of this weird regulation.
- I don't know what they're auditing.
- I think it's to make
sure that the right parties
are paid for the phone calls,
like the collect calls,
the calls that cost
money that's not coinage.
I don't know, again, I didn't
read that much about it,
I just know that they're going away
but having read about them,
I began to think I should be
using payphones more often.
- Why?
I mean do you have a strong memory
of having a great experience
in a payphone booth?
- I've never had a great
experience in a payphone booth.
- But I mean, I was
always afraid to touch it,
like put it up to my ear, it just seems--
- You don't have to touch it,
you can just get a nice distance.
- They were very weighty,
like I remember the few times
you pick up a, just next
time you go by a payphone--
- Well of course they are.
- Just pick it up
and pick up that receiver
and that thing is heavy.
- Do you know why it's
gotta be so durable?
Think of all the people who--
- Yeah people just--
- Slamming it against,
slamming it down on the thing
after a bad phone call.
- Yeah 'cause a lot
of the times you're in some
sort of frustrated situation.
On a payphone trying to call home.
- I'd like to have a phone
that durable at home.
- Well you could probably buy a payphone
and hook it up at your house.
- I'm sure there's somebody.
- You don't have a landline, do you?
- I do.
- You do?
- I do and I'm gonna talk--
- I had a landline.
- I'm gonna talk about my
landline in the context
of another, do you remember so-and-so?
- Well the one on my list
that you're reminding me of is beepers.
Remember beepers?
- Beepers, man.
- So before--
- Beepers, the new jeepers.
- AKA pagers, before
cell phones came about
and even as they were
starting to catch hold,
people were having beepers
in like the early 90s.
They're like, I mean I think
there was a drug culture
around beepers, there was also like--
- Oh, hold on, hold on.
That's an interesting--
- I mean I wasn't involved.
- I think there might have been
a drug culture around beepers,
meaning drug dealers all had beepers?
Yes, that's what you meant.
- I mean it was also
just something I learned
about in hip-hop, like there
was A Tribe Called Quest song
called the Skypager.
- Oh, Skypager.
- Yeah, and The Low End
Theory and I was like oh,
it's gonna be cool to have a beeper,
and then fast-forward many years
later, I become an engineer
and I was issued a beeper.
- A beeper.
I never had one.
- I had a beeper, dude.
- Made you feel powerful.
You feel like Batman or at least Robin.
- I had to read about how it worked.
Even though I carried it
around for a couple years--
- It beeped, man.
- I couldn't remember.
I would have to travel
between different facilities,
like I'd get in my car
and drive around and--
- Did you have it on
the outside of a belt?
- It would be on, where you
want, put it in my underwear?
- Well some people put it in a pocket.
- I'm an engineer, man, I'm walking around
with my shirt tucked in and I got a belt.
That's back when I used to wear belts
and I would hang it on
the belt with pride.
- Well and you should
have, I'm just saying,
you don't wear belts now.
I never see you in a belt.
- So the beeper is like,
if I was talking to my kids
about this or if you never heard of it,
it's a device that then, it
has a phone number associated
with it and when you
dial the phone number,
then it makes this noise
and then you can enter
in other numbers with your
phone and then those numbers
that you enter in will
show up on the beeper
when it beeps and typically you would just
put your phone number in the beeper
and so then when you sent
it, my beeper would beep
and I would look at it and
it would have a phone number
on it and that's the number
that I would then call
once I got to a phone.
- Right, but the person calling
didn't have to do anything
except call the beeper.
- They had to put in their message
because sometimes you would put in,
you'd put in a phone number
and then you'd put 911
and that wouldn't mean
there was an emergency,
it would just mean call me
back as soon as possible,
this is urgent.
Or--
- Didn't people call them buzzers as well?
- Uh, no.
- No one called 'em buzzers?
- Never.
Not in--
- Pager.
- Skypage.
- Skypager, beeper, and if you put like--
- Buzzers.
Just call 'em a buzz.
- 143.
143 just meant I love you.
- I love you.
- So other engineers
would say they love me
occasionally I guess.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
That's sweet.
- And it made you feel important
when you were in the middle
of a conversation or you're
walking around a facility
and all of a sudden you're
beeping, you're like,
and I would--
- Just got paged.
- I would have to--
- Just got buzzed.
- I remember I had this
cool technique of like
(mimics whip lash) I would
pull it off of my belt
and look at it 'cause--
- I'm sure it was very cool.
- The numbers were so small
you had to really hold it up
to your eye and that was a way
to tell everybody around you,
I have been issues a beeper.
I can see you don't have one.
- A functioning beeper.
- I have a functioning beeper
so then I would just run,
then you run to the nearest
phone to answer a 911.
- Yeah, doctors, speaking of 911,
I mean doctors all had them, right?
- They still do, actually.
Beepers are still in effect to use--
- Somebody's got to.
- The terminology.
Because they operate on, they
don't operate on cell service,
they operate on a much
more reliable service.
- Really?
- Yes.
And that's why--
- What are they operating on?
- Firemen, doctors--
- Medical personnel--
- Different frequencies?
- Yeah it's a different--
- The beeper frequency.
- I think it's like a radio wave I think.
- Well I think they're all
radio waves to some degree
just different frequencies,
I don't know.
- Maybe so.
- I never had one but
now you made me feel like
I should get one of those too.
I should get one of those and
beep myself in a payphone.
- Well I mean, and you're
the most reliably reachable
and then you could have a two-way pager
when you could page something,
you could page a number back.
I did not have one of those.
I was not a second-level
manager at IBM as they call it.
I was just a first-level.
- A peon.
- So you never even experienced that.
You never had a beeper.
- No, I never had a beeper.
- Ha!
- I never had a reason to have a beeper.
- Nobody wanted to beep me.
- What a loser, I mean what
a just unimportant person
you must have been.
- Yeah I was.
I was siloed.
- I was very important.
I had to be reached.
- Do you remember--
- For nothing.
- Dialing 411.
- Information.
- Now 411, people use it as
slang, well at least in the 90s.
I think they still do,
what's the 411 on that,
give me the download, give me the info.
And of course this is based on the fact
that you could dial 411,
and you still can dial 411 but
this was a reliable service
before the internet to--
- Yes.
Well to get a phone number.
- Usually just to get
a phone number of a place.
- Yeah, then you could
call them and get the more,
whatever, talk to 'em.
- You could also get
an address of a place.
- Oh really?
- Yeah you could get information, I think.
I never used it.
Literally never used it and I don't know,
I don't know why 'cause
it's a real person,
it's not a machine, it's a real person.
- It still exists?
- It still exists and
we're going to call it.
- Ha, okay, all right.
So are you gonna ask for a number?
- Well, let's find out, bro.
- Whatever that means.
What?
Let's do it in English.
- Des Moines, Iowa.
Resibolsh.
- What are you doing?
- [Automated Voice] That's
county of Poke, right?
- No.
I would like to speak to a human.
- You wanna speak to a human?
Yes!
- Yeah!
- We're about to get a 411 operator.
- Yeah, just real quick, I'm actually,
I don't need a listing in Des Moines,
but I just wanted, if
you have a quick second
to just talk about 411 as a service.
- What?
(line trilling)
- Supervisor.
I'm sorry, yeah, I said Des Moines, Iowa,
but really what I meant
was, I'm currently talking
to a friend about 411 service and the fact
that it still exists and
we wanted to call and just,
how popular is this service still?
Oh wow, so--
- What kinda information
can you get?
- So how long have you been,
how long have you been doing it?
20 years, so how much
smaller is the department
than it was 20 years ago?
- Can we get--
- Wow, okay, and we were just talking,
we used to call to get phone numbers
but you can get phone numbers, addresses,
what all can you still get?
- Yelp reviews?
- No, can't do Yelp reviews.
- What movies have you seen lately?
- Okay.
Well how about Bob Jenkins
in Des Moines, Iowa?
(line beeps)
- Bob Jenkins.
If you remember--
- I tried.
- Bob Jenkins, just call back.
So basically you can't conduct
a relationship with 411.
They just can't chat.
- You screwed that up for me, man.
I was having, that's why I
was telling you be quiet.
I was having a great
conversation with that woman.
She completely opened up, she
was like I've been doing it
for 20 years, it's a
lot smaller, and like,
"What movies have you seen
lately?" and then she got pissed,
man, and she wanted to go.
- She said you couldn't chat.
- She could have chatted with me.
That woman would have talked
to me for 17 to 20 minutes.
And it would have been amazing.
We didn't even get her name.
- 20 years of just giving
people exactly what they need.
That's probably satisfying and draining.
- She sounds satisfied.
(both chuckle)
So I never called it, did you call it?
- I don't recall ever
calling 411 but I'm sure,
I mean my mom wanted to see if
the Golden Corral was
open early or something.
- I just used the phone book.
- That's so much work,
you gotta like think about
where things fall in the alphabet.
Phone book, that's another
thing we don't use anymore.
I mean they'll still stack
up a phone book in front
of my house and I'll put it
directly in the recycle bin.
I feel guilty about it.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Boy that was thrilling.
I wrote down--
- That was what?
- Thrilling.
- Oh.
I didn't know what you said. (chuckles)
- What about dialing star 69?
- Oh, now I've done that.
- Star 69.
Now if you beeped star 69,
that means something else.
- It sounds dirty.
- But if you dial star 69,
it would give you the last
number that called you.
- Yeah, it was what killed prank calling.
- Yes.
- But if you were
prank calling, you could
dial, what could you dial
to make your number
unlisted before you dial it?
Star what?
- Star 68 or something,
there was like, star 96?
You could block your
call, before you dialed,
you could do that in order
to block people's ability
to see--
- I don't know what it was.
- On caller ID.
- Yeah you could dial something.
We did it all the time.
It was the counter to star 69.
- Star 69 was, it was like
if the phone was ringing
and you couldn't get to it.
- Yeah.
You were kind of, yeah, you
wanted to know who called you.
- And you didn't have an answering machine
or they didn't leave an answer.
I guess it would just drive people nuts
so they would pay extra.
- Who was that that called?
- What?
Star 67 was how you blocked your number.
- Blocked being star 69ed.
- I would assume that this
still all works on landlines.
Like I said, I've got
one, I'm gonna test it.
- I don't remember using
that one that much.
If I didn't answer the phone,
again, you would just like,
who was that, I don't know,
they'll call back later.
- We also weren't adults--
- Right.
- When this was the way things were.
I think I did, I probably
did it a couple of times
thinking that maybe I'd gotten
a phone call from a girl
or something, you know.
- I remember--
- But--
- Another thing on my
list that I did do was
I would, all the phones in
your house were connected,
so it wasn't like every person
had their own phone line.
I mean gosh.
- Party line, man.
Or at least within the house.
- Yeah within the house
and so if my step-sister
at the time was talking to her boyfriend,
I could pick up my
Garfield phone gingerly.
- His eyes would open.
- And then I would just like listen.
I would cover up--
- Hold on.
- The top hole.
- You eavesdropped.
- Just listen to this,
see what I could learn.
- What did you learn?
- I don't know, nothing, I
don't know, I know a lot now.
So probably some of it came from them.
You know, it's like--
- You were that little brother,
that little step-brother,
not even half-brother.
- Yeah.
- That little step-brother.
- I wasn't addicted to it.
I didn't do it constantly
but I would do it sometimes.
- Man, violating of privacy.
I never listened to my
brother's phone calls.
I was afraid to do that.
- But the parents could
listen to them too.
Just get a little, I mean,
but you would hear that breathing.
They'd be like, "Get off the phone, Link!"
I would get that.
I'm saying she would hear my breathing.
- You gotta be better than
to let the breaths be heard.
- Well a man gotta breathe.
- You pull away from the
microphone to breathe.
- So, or you would just be on,
and my mom still has a
landline and I'll call
and Lewis will answer, I'm talking to him
and then he'll talk to me for awhile
and then all of a sudden
he'll just be like, "Sue!"
And then Mom will get on
the phone in the bedroom,
then they're both on the phone.
That's very--
- It's so easy.
Two people at a speakerphone is--
- That's something that
is lost, that was nice.
- And it cannot be replicated.
- Yeah,
without the landline.
- Two people--
- I don't have a landline.
- On a close microphone
speaking into your ear,
it's like a conference call.
- Yeah it's like I have conference
calls with family members
all the time, you know?
- Mm-hmm.
- Mom and Lewis in different
rooms just talking away.
- Hmm.
Well--
- I would talk to my mom
for a long time and then I realized
Lewis would all of a
sudden after talking to her
for like 20 minutes, all of a sudden then
Lewis will be like, "Well, I'm gonna go.
"I'm gonna let the two of y'all talk."
It's like oh, he's been
on here this whole time.
(Rhett laughs)
I forgot, I kinda forgot
he was still on here.
Good, good, good.
- He could take 20 minutes of it.
I still do have a landline.
We got it, well, when you get like the--
- They try to make you get it.
- You get the service
and stuff, you can get it,
and my wife was like, yeah let's get it,
because, you know, we've got kids.
If they need to get in touch with us.
'Cause at the time, when we
bought the current house,
neither of the kids had a cell phone.
- Right.
But if they're there and they
need to call 911 or something.
- And Shepherd doesn't have
a cell phone and sometimes,
for short stints, he's on his own.
Like when we go out on the
prairie to bring back a deer.
- Okay.
- He'll spend a few fortnights alone.
(chuckles) No, but a few
minutes alone sometimes,
and it's like Shepherd,
if anything happens,
so I remember, I was
like, I had to show them
how to use the phone and
apparently it's not as simple
as I remember, at least,
they did not understand,
no, you pick it up, it's making a noise.
That's called a dial tone.
Then you have to press the buttons,
like just the fact that
they're pressing buttons
that are not on a touch screen--
- It's weird.
- They couldn't press them
all the way in to know that
they had registered the number
and it's just like all these
little things are like,
actually you didn't hit
that, you didn't hit it,
you know why you didn't hit it?
'Cause you didn't hear it.
When you hit the number,
you'll hear a (mimics beep),
the associated tone with
that particular number.
- Yeah dial--
- Eventually they got it.
- You're right, the
dial tones don't exist.
Give me another one off your list.
- Remembering phone numbers.
- (chuckles) Right.
Yeah, there was a time in
our lives when there was like
drawers in my brain that were dedicated
to people's phone numbers.
- I thought we could have
a fun little exercise.
Now obviously Kiko we're
going to have to edit these.
But I want to throw out
someone's phone number
from the past, now let's start with--
- Well I think it--
- Let's start with,
I'm gonna start with your
phone number when you lived
in that part, before you
moved to Gregory Circle.
- My first house, yeah.
My first house.
(tones beeping)
Yeah, that's it.
(laughs excitedly)
- That's crazy!
Hold on, 'cause how
old were you when you--
- I mean first of all--
- How old were you when you
moved to Gregory Circle?
What grade?
- I think I was 12.
- Right so we're talking about,
I just recall your phone
number from first, second,
third, fourth, fifth grade.
- 28--
- The first five years
of our friendship.
- Yeah.
And then I moved and do you
remember my phone number
once I moved, this is more recent.
This one should be a little easier.
(tones beeping)
That's it.
(laughs excitedly)
- What?
- You were in one house.
- That's crazy!
- So I know,
yours is easy. (tones beeping)
- Yes.
- So that's easy.
But do you remember our
phone number in college?
Maybe it was our dorm room number.
- Not a clue.
Not a clue.
Like that is--
- It was the NC State numbers were--
(tones beep)
- Mm-hmm.
- You remember the next part?
- No.
(tones beep)
Oh, okay.
- Isn't that it?
- Okay interestingly,
I've had (tones beeping),
I think I've actually
used that for things.
- Oh like your password?
- No.
- Like your bank pin?
- No when you're trying
to find, when you're trying to,
I don't have anything that has that now,
but like a Google number
or something like that.
- I mean I don't know
your phone number now.
Like I knew your North
Carolina phone number.
- I don't know my phone number now.
Maybe I do.
- When you got a new phone
number, I don't know it.
And that's gone.
- Right so--
- Like I know my wife's
number, I know my number,
I mean we've had 'em a long time.
I don't know my kids' phone numbers.
That's actually a bit scary, right?
- Well so I wanna talk about
that, specifically related.
So obviously there were
very good reasons to know
these phone numbers, but,
and I still know your phone number
because it's the phone number that you got
the same year that I got
my original phone number,
the North Carolina phone number.
I've changed my phone number. (chuckles)
But you should know your family members',
all your immediate family
and then you should also know
emergency contact like next of kin.
You should have those memorized.
- This is kind of a wake-up call.
Or we should just re, we should use 411.
My kids need to get in
touch with me, 411 it.
- Yeah but you might not be in 411.
In fact--
- I should not be.
- If we've done things the
right way, you're not in 411.
- That's true, we should test that.
- But okay 'cause I have this fear,
going back to speaking
of payphones, it's like,
okay, run out of gas with a dead phone.
Like that's a bit of a, running out of gas
with a phone that's not currently working.
- Vultures circling.
- And I'm talking about,
I'm not talking about being
out in the wilderness,
I'm talking about just being in Anaheim,
you know what I'm saying,
at that point, you're like,
okay now I'm gonna be the
guy that goes up to people
and says, "Can I use your phone?"
And now, I'm not a gracious
person when strangers come up
to me in need, I always just
assume that they're scammers.
- And it kinda feels like
can I use your tooth brush.
- Right.
- Pretty intimate.
- 'Cause you know, 'cause
you've got those people
who come up to you at the gas station--
- Like I use this thing
on the crapper, man.
- You got those people that come up to you
at the gas station and they've got a story
and then they go up to every person.
You know that this is a
scam, like 99% of the time,
it's a scam.
- You're gonna hand 'em
your phone, they're just gonna run?
- No they're not asking for the phone,
they're asking for like a couple of bucks
or something like that.
And just as a policy, I don't do,
I give to a lot of things, but
I don't give to those people
because I think that, I can't verify--
- Shady.
- It just seems shady right.
But I don't wanna be
that guy that has to go
and ask a stranger for the phone.
Now I guess I would go to the payphone.
- And even if you did,
you wouldn't know what number to call.
- Right, yeah, so double whammy
if you get in that situation
and you don't know the number,
so I guess we do now know
that 411 is still available
but I don't think that a lot
of people that we would want
to call are on 411.
- Mm-mm.
- So I know my wife's phone
number, got that memorized.
It's the same one that
she had when I got her
her first cell phone when
she was 20 years old.
So I think I'm okay but I don't know,
I don't know my parents' phone number--
- My kids know my number.
They know my number.
- I think my kids know my new number.
They definitely know Jessie's number.
- But how would you know if they knew it
'cause you don't know it.
You'd have to pull it up
on your phone I guess.
- But beyond those numbers that you need
for emergency situations, it does not,
other than just for your
own personal memory exercise
and trying to stave off
degenerative disease
or something like that,
there's really no reason to
keep your numbers in your head
because you can easily just
offload it to your phone
and if you are seriously
one of those people
that you do not have, I
guess there are still people
out there who have a
smartphone but do not have
their contacts backed
up in a cloud situation,
with some service.
You need to do that.
There's no reason that your
phone should be the only place
that you have these phone numbers.
Make an adjustment.
- All right I got another one.
- You'll thank me later.
- On my list of, speaking of
dialing things for information.
We would dial a number
and it was the local bank.
- First Federal Bank.
- To get the exact time.
And temperature.
- Hold on, I'm assuming that you wrote
this phone number down
so we could call it.
- I wrote down, well, I looked
it up and it doesn't exist.
So I have another number
that yes we could call.
- Hold on, I called the First
Federal number literally
and I think I can remember this number.
- 'Cause here's what happened--
- What was the number, do
you remember that number?
- A lightning would strike.
A lightning would strike.
- Just one lightning.
- Power would go out and then you're like,
I gotta reset my phone
so how do you do that?
You call the bank, First Federal time.
- Seven--
- 10:58.
- Right.
First Federal temperature, 49 degrees.
- Yeah.
Yeah so you called it
for time when you need
to reset the time, you
called it for temperature
when you wanna know
what the temperature was
and you didn't wanna sit
around and wait for Greg Fishel
to come on and tell you
what the temperature was.
- Yeah and--
- I called it all the time,
when I was getting ready to go to school
and I was like how cold is it outside?
I would call First Federal so I could get
the frickin' temperature
to know if I needed
to put a jacket on.
- I watched the weather for that but--
- You watched the weather when?
- Every morning.
- Every morning?
You watched the weather in the morning?
- Oh yeah, I loved the weather man.
Literally I loved the weather man.
- [Rhett] Loved the weather man.
- [Link] I thought that
was a great profession.
- So you're telling me that
you can't call that number
'cause I swear within the last five years
I've called that number
when I was at home.
- Well there's lots of places
where you could call POPCORN,
767-2676 and get a pre-recorded
voice telling you the time.
That does not work anymore
but you can dial 202-762-1401,
which I think is the Naval Observatory
and it'll give you the
exact Eastern Standard Time.
So let's call that one, let's
figure out what time it is.
And this will be Eastern Standard Time.
There's a Mountain Standard Time number.
(line trilling)
I assume there's a Pacific.
- [Automated Voice] U.S. Naval
Observatory master clock,
at the tone, Eastern Standard Time.
21 hours, 10 minutes, 15 seconds.
(beeps)
- Wow.
- Universal time,
two hours, 10 minutes, 20 seconds.
U.S. Naval Observatory
master clock, at the tone,
Eastern Standard Time.
21 hours, 10 minutes, 30 seconds. (beeps)
Universal time--
- Beep.
- Two hours, 10 minutes,
35 seconds.
- He's repeating himself now.
- I like that guy's voice.
- Yeah I want that guy to be my Siri.
Is that possible?
- No, it's not.
So yeah I mean we used to
dial a number to figure out
what time it was.
- Now I should probably
should have talked about this
with remembering phone
numbers but, Rolodex.
- Rolodex?
- The Rolodex.
- You talking about an address
book that is on a swivel.
- You didn't have one
of these at your house?
(vibrates tongue)
- No, I never had a Rolodex.
That's something that an ad man
in like Mad Man had on their desk.
You had a Rolodex?
- We had a version of a Rolodex that,
I needed to know like,
what is my cousin's number
or something like that.
My mom would go and all
the cards were organized
and she would flip through 'em.
It was a Rolodex.
It was a--
- You would roll around.
- It may not have been
the brand name Rolodex
which I'm gonna tell you about
because it's absolutely fascinating.
- Tell me about it.
- Okay so the Rolodex
which just to explain,
it was basically this
ringed collection of cards
that you could write numbers and names on
and organize them by alphabetical
order and put anything,
any information you want.
This thing was invented by--
- Roll E. Dex.
- Arnold Neustadter.
He was a 20th century
inventor from Brooklyn.
Now he also invented,
before this, the Swivodex,
which was a device that kept
ink bottles from spilling.
I don't know for what purpose.
- Well 'cause you don't
wanna spill your ink, man.
- He also invented the Clipodex.
- Oh wow.
- Sensing a theme here.
Arnold.
- What is that for?
Paper clips?
- It was a device that
attached to the knees of stenographers.
To keep their pads from moving.
- Oh wow.
- Pads, the ones that were on their knees.
And he also made, he changed things up.
The Punched.
- Punched.
- Which was a hole-puncher,
made holes in papers.
Now, then he came along--
- Prolific inventor.
- With the Rolodex.
Now the funny thing is is
there was an article in Gizmodo
by Anna Jane Grossman who
wrote that book Obsolete
which I did not read but saw the cover of
and thought I would like to read,
which is like 98% of books with me.
And she talked about how,
the daughter talked about how
the dad was really anal and he
tried to remember everything
and whenever someone, she
took a message from someone,
he would be like, "I want
you to get their name,
"their callback number, their address,
"the reason for calling," he had this list
that you had to do in the
household if you took a message.
So this was right down his alley
was to organize information
in this way.
- By the way,
that is a flashback for
me is being taught how
to take messages for people in the house.
Like for my mom and dad--
- Name, number,
and reason for calling.
- And you'd write it down.
So as a kid I remember that system.
- Did you have to say the
residence or did you say hello?
We didn't have to do,
"McLaughlin residence."
- I would say hello but I
think the Jubees did like--
- Oh the Jubee residence.
- Jubee residence.
- Anybody with class did residence.
- We didn't do that.
- We didn't have class.
(chuckles) So he invented this in the 50s.
Then, by the 80s, the Rolodex
had become such an icon
that lawsuits were filed
by companies who accused
former employees of taking
them with them when they left.
It was like, he's taking
his Rolodex with him,
is a euphemism but it's
based in a literal truth
in that depending on what
the business you were in,
like a ad man like you were talking about,
your Rolodex, your physical
Rolodex was incredibly valuable.
- The contacts that you made.
You're talking about backing
up your contacts to the cloud.
- Yes.
- Yeah that thing became
extremely valuable for business contacts.
- They didn't have backup
Rolodexes I don't think,
because, okay so models were
selling for $200 at the time.
Even though people often valued
them at prices far higher
than that once they got
filled up, listen to this.
- Sure.
- In fact,
an entire episode of Moonlighting,
remember Moonlighting
with Bruce Willis, sitcom.
- Cybill Shepherd.
- Was devoted to one stolen
Rolodex being held ransom
for $50,000, an entire episode.
- It's a fictional world but--
- That was fictional
but Rolodex--
- Still stands.
- Up to $50,000 in a fictional world.
- You know it would be cool to,
I bet you you can buy
Rolodexes now off of eBay
that are like fully populated
and that would be fascinating.
- Yeah it would but you
can also buy brand new ones
because--
- I'm not into that.
- In the interview that this
woman, this author conducted
with the daughter of Arnold--
- Mm-hmm.
- She said, "I'm talking about
this for my book Obsolete,"
and the girl got a little
upset and was like,
"They're not obsolete.
"People still buy them, still use them.
"They're still sold."
She probably says that
because she gets a little bit
of that money even to this day.
- My Nana and Papa they
didn't have a Rolodex,
they would get, the phone
was beside the calendar
and then the top of the
calendar had an area where
you would write down
numbers so every year,
they would kinda have to
start over, like transfer over
the most important numbers.
And then she'd scribble all
over the top of the calendar
and was like, by the end of the year,
it would have numbers all over it.
- And then she would repeat
the ones that she wanted
to hold onto.
- I think so.
She must have, I mean--
- It's an interesting system.
Doesn't seem very efficient
but at the same time--
- You know, 'cause they're on the phone--
- You can re-evaluate every single year.
- You're on the phone
and you're just like,
oh I'm gonna write down your
number or write down the number
I need to call and then you call it.
That's where you need it anyway.
- What if Bob Jenkins in Des
Moines, Iowa is listening
to this podcast.
- He is, he is.
- He's freakin' out.
- Remember just answering machines?
- Yeah.
- I remember, I mean,
I don't even use voicemail.
- It's just a black hole for me, man.
- My mom called me this
morning, she was like,
"I was calling you and I was
trying to leave a voicemail
"and you called me back," and I'm like,
I almost said, "Don't leave
voicemails, just text me."
- Yeah.
- Voicemails, voice mailboxes are obsolete
but I remember whenever we
would come home from anything,
as a kid, I would run into the living room
and I would press play
on our cassette tape run
answering machine and you'd hear the beep.
Beep, and then you'd hear the recording.
The analog recording that somebody left
and then it would beep
again letting them know,
oh you're almost out of time.
And sometimes they'd have to call back,
leave a second voicemail
to continue their thought.
- Right.
- And then,
I don't know, it was an
exciting moment because
every second that you're out in the world,
you're not receiving calls, you know.
It's this sensation of like a build-up
of expectations, like, well,
there was always something
to look forward to.
Like I said, I would bust in the door
and I couldn't wait to hear
who had left a message.
- On your mom's answering machine?
- Yeah, it was just exciting to me.
I bet--
- I don't remember--
- Something happened while we
were gone, somebody called.
- Well first of all, I
definitely did not have
an answering machine
when I was living at home
with my parents, they did not have one.
- They didn't, your family
didn't own an answering machine?
- Not for the longest time.
- I remember when we got it.
- Maybe at the very
tail end of high school.
- I was very fascinated by it.
- I don't think we had one.
And I think that...
- That's weird.
- Well I don't think it's that weird.
I think there's a lot of
families that didn't have
an answering machine.
- It's one of those things
that once you had it--
- Maybe I'm blocking it
out but I'm pretty sure
that we did not have one for a majority--
- [Link] It felt like we
couldn't live without it.
- Of the time that I
lived there, and then,
did we have an answering machine
in the college dorm room?
'Cause I know I had one
when I first got married.
- No, our college dorm
room phone number had--
- A voicemail.
- Had voicemail boxes.
Like you would pick up the phone
and the dial tone would be different.
- Different.
- And then--
- If it was beeping, if
it was a broken dial tone,
that meant that you had a message.
- You had a message and then
you would put in your code
and it would lead to either
my voice box, well voicemail.
It'd lead to my voice
box, I would be speaking.
- Yeah my code 1958. (chuckles)
- But do you remember the commercial
where they would sell greetings
and it was called Crazy Calls.
- [Announcer] Crazy Calls, a
tape of seven different songs
and funny recordings
for answering machines.
- No.
♪ Nobody's home ♪
♪ Nobody's home, nobody's
home, nobody's home ♪
And then there was--
- Hold on.
You didn't use this service.
- I just remember, I wanted it so bad.
- How would you get it onto
your answering machine?
- It was seven songs, I looked this up,
it was called Crazy Calls and
it was seven different tracks
on a cassette tape that would
fit in your answering machine
and your answering
machine would know how to,
it would queue up the
tape and then play it
and then it would record, but
sometimes it would have to
fast forward--
- This is one tape?
One tape has the greeting
and the messages?
- No, it's a separate tape.
There was a greeting tape
and then a recording tape.
That's how it worked.
And I remember there was a
rap on there that was like
♪ Leave your message ♪
♪ We're not home but leave
your message at the tone ♪
And then it would--
- That's a good one.
- It was one that was like,
wait for the beep
Wait for the beep.
It kept saying that.
It was like a rapper.
- And there's also the classic, hello.
- That wasn't one of the seven.
- Gotcha, I'm not home!
- It's too annoying.
- Whoever did that should
be ashamed of yourself.
- I wanted those tapes so bad.
- But you're right.
- That was the peak of
technology for me was like--
- Little tapes.
- Oh and the, oh, we got that one too.
First it was the bigger
tapes and then you would get
an answering machine that
would have those little tapes
that you'd put the hand recorder,
it was like note to self.
- But then it went to, the one we had
when we first got married was no tape.
- Yeah kinda digital or something.
- It was being recorded
locally in there somehow.
And we had that for,
we had a regular phone
with an answering machine up
until they started putting
voicemail built into your phone service,
which happened, it was widespread sometime
in like the early 2000s.
That's when you just
started doing it that way.
- Did you have anything else on your list?
- I did.
Phones with cables.
- The tether.
Yeah, the spiral cordage.
- The phone I have at
home has a cable on it.
It's not cordless, 'cause I remember--
- Really.
- When my mom
got a cordless phone
and we were like, what?
She can walk room to
room while on the phone
and it was just like
we are rich. (chuckles)
- I remember the first
time I got that, yeah.
I remember first time we got one of those,
I probably called you.
But I remember walking
out on the front lawn,
I was like I'm in my lawn!
- I'm outside talking on the phone.
- I'm so rich!
- I'm blowing my own mind.
(chuckles)
- My neighbors can see me!
- Yeah because before that--
- I'm talking on
the phone outdoors!
- Well and you had to think
about where the phones were.
I mean everybody, most people
had a phone in every room.
Like you had a phone in each bedroom
so you could have those
conversations with lady friends
and you didn't want your
parents to hear, but even then,
you had the phone and then you had,
you stretch the cord if you
wanted to sit in your chair
or lay down on your bed and you got like,
you know the cord, it's tethered, man.
- Yeah.
- Maybe you could get
the whole phone, like you
could take all of Garfield
and bring him into bed with you,
but you gotta make sure
that the cord from Garfield
to the wall is long enough for that.
- Right, and I do remember back to like
the in the house party line thing,
what would actually happen
the most, not me eavesdropping
on my step-sister would
be I would be on the phone
with my girlfriend or something,
and then my mom on the
other side of the house
would need to make a phone call
and she would just pick up
the phone and I'd be like,
"Mom, I'm on the phone."
It was like, and then
she was, "Oh I'm sorry."
And then she'd be like, "Well
I need to use the phone, so."
- And cordless phones--
- "You need to get off."
- "You can get back on
"after I call."
- Were much easier to tell--
- Time and date.
- When somebody
had interrupted.
So if you had the classic
phone, either rotary phone
or just a non-corded phone,
a non-cordless phone.
You get your finger and you'd
stick it up under the receiver
and hold down those two clear
pegs that would come out
that would indicate that
this phone was open,
the phone line's open.
You'd hold it down and
then you'd open it up.
You'd get the phone in position.
- Then you'd--
- Turn it like this
so you wouldn't breathe into the phone
and then you very,
very, very quietly lift.
- So you did eavesdrop on your brother.
- No, I just knew how to do it.
I just know the technique.
- You had the power but
you didn't wield it.
- But with a cordless
phone, it was very obvious,
like (clicks tongue), you
could hear (clicks tongue)
somebody just (clicks tongue)
came into the conversation.
- Yeah.
It's like, "Mom, I'm on the phone!
"Buh!"
- And then every once in awhile,
you can replicate the situation
when you're charging your
phone and you get a phone call
and you don't wanna stop charging it.
And you're like down there
next to your bedside table
with a--
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you can feel--
- I'm doing it the old-fashioned way.
- You can feel what it
was like to be tethered.
- Did you have anything else?
- Mm-mm.
- But you do, I think, as our custom now,
have a recommendation for
all the Ear Biscuiteers.
- So thanks for taking
a trip down memory lane.
Let us know #EarBiscuits,
what phone-related nostalgia
was brought to your mind.
Something you remember about
the way phones used to be.
#EarBiscuits.
And now it's time to
get some recs in effect.
- I'm gonna work on that.
- I'm gonna check baby
check baby, you know.
It's Rump Shaker.
It's a song.
- Yeah, right.
- Speaking of, my recommendation
this week is a song.
I love it when I find
a song, it's like whoa,
I'm, something about this song is special
and I never even knew it existed.
- Hmm.
- I played this for Rhett earlier today.
- Yes.
- Would you agree that this
is a song not to be missed.
- It's very notable.
- It's weird.
- I think it has special,
I knew when you were
playing it exactly why
you were playing it for me.
I don't necessarily know
that that would translate
to everyone.
- Right.
- But you were playing it
for me because you were like,
the person who sang this song
at the time that they sang it
and then the way that it sounds,
all of those things are gonna
be a little bit difficult
for you to reconcile and
it's gonna be a little bit
of a trip and you were right, my friend.
- Yeah and so, I don't know
where it's gonna strike you.
And I will say that I'm
not giving an endorsement
of anybody's, of this
artist's personal beliefs
or what they may put on Twitter, now.
- No telling.
Does he have a Twitter account?
- Yeah.
So don't go there, just enjoy
the song for what it is.
But the song is called Behind Your Eyes
by The Charlie Daniels Band.
- Mm-hmm.
- You may know The
Charlie Daniels Band from
The Devil Went Down to Georgia.
He was looking for a soul to steal.
He was in a bind, he was way behind
and he was willing to make a deal.
- Mm-hmm.
- Fiddle song.
- That's what he's known for most.
- Even when we went to
New Orleans and we went to
that dueling piano bar--
- Of course--
- They started playing
that song--
- Right, got to.
- It's a good song.
- Yeah.
- But this song Behind Your Eyes,
(chuckles) is the song before
that song on the album,
and it is like night and
day different in terms
of like the genre.
It's not this like, you may consider
Devil Went Down to Georgia
like a redneck fiddle song.
- Mm-hmm, I think that's the
official genre on iTunes.
Redneck fiddle.
- The sound and the
production of that song
was just very unexpected
for Charlie Daniels Band.
- It's got this late
70s rock kind of thing
and then these, which is
one of my favorite things.
- Harmonic.
- Yeah, harmonizing lead guitars.
Like two telecasters
playing complementary solos.
- It's not limited to but it
is a big southern rock thing
when he was in that zone.
- There's just something about it.
- I think this is 1979.
- It's a good year.
- So yeah, just think of me
when you listen to that song
and it may surprise you.
- Here's to being surprised--
- That's my recommendation.
- You know what, you gotta
keep surprising yourself.
Don't ever stop surprising yourself.
Go outside on your phone,
talk in the yard, untethered.
- If you don't know your own
phone number, memorize that.
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- Starting with you, Rhett.
- Yeah I'm gonna do that.
- All right, we'll speak at you next week.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)